what exactly did it take for heath
ledger to pull off his oscar-winning
joker performance does the diary he kept
at the time hold any clues about his
tragic death keep watching for the
answers
over a decade after it first appeared on
the big screen heath ledger's rendition
of the joker in 2008's the dark knight
stands above all other super villain
portrayals he came across as cold
thoughtful and scarily real bringing the
clown prince of crime to life in a new
and impactful way pulling off such a
chilling performance didn't come easy
and was the result of impressive
dedication on the part of the man behind
the makeup heath ledger took his acting
work incredibly seriously and didn't shy
away from an opportunity to push himself
as an artist he'd envelop himself in his
characters to ensure he got every
mannerism line and facial expression
just right no matter the nature of the
project director christopher nolan's
vision of joker was no exception and as
it turns out ledger took his methodology
to the next level for the part with a
disturbing diary while much of the
diary's content playing cards comic
panels and various quotes from the dark
knight centers on the joker it also
contains many extra images and writings
these give fans a glimpse into ledger's
mind as he delved deeper down the rabbit
hole the small book has become almost as
legendary as the character itself
leading fans and critics to praise
ledger for his unsettling commitment to
his craft because of the foreboding
nature of its content however it comes
with its fair share of urban legends to
truly become the joker heath ledger
chose to isolate himself from the rest
of the world for months at a time
locking himself in his apartment or
hotel room to iron out the finer details
of the character during his exile he'd
work on his diary free of distraction he
documented his thought process important
quirks to the character and other notes
that describe how he came up with so
many now iconic parts of the joker's
characterization in a german documentary
about the late actor titled too young to
die heath ledger his father kim ledger
was interviewed on the unorthodox nature
of his son's preparation while the elder
ledger admitted that the isolation and
prolonged study was nothing new for his
son he described the joker journal as
being on a whole new level even as
bizarre as its content seemed on its own
the two strategies ledger utilized in
tandem were undeniably crucial to
perfecting his performance
the diary is full of clippings from
comic books which ledger read in
isolation pages of the diary are filled
with handwritten versions of the joker's
dialogue from his scenes including the
infamous moment when the joker detonates
a bomb in a gotham city hospital in the
documentary kim mentions that when they
were kids ledger's older sister kate
would dress him in a nurse's uniform
like he wears in the movie when ledger
described his version of the character
to empire in 2007 he said i ended up
landing more in the realm of a
psychopath someone with very little to
no conscience towards zacks he's just an
absolute sociopath a cold-blooded mass
murdering clown
let's not
blow this out of proportion ledger also
told empire about christopher nolan's
input on the character leisure said
chris has given me free reign which is
fun because there are no real boundaries
to what the joker would say or do
nothing intimidates him and everything
is a big joke on set ledger often
improvised moments during scenes and
ledger rarely told christopher nolan
exactly what he was planning to do the
unpredictability made directing his
scenes much more intense than usual one
of the most memorable moments in the
film that ledger improvised takes place
during the scene when jim gordon played
by gary oldman gets promoted to police
commissioners shortly after capturing
the joker the joker in a nearby prison
cell sarcastically claps along with
everyone else
among the many seemingly random images
and frantic scribblings inside ledger's
diary were a handful of references to
stanley kubrick's 1971 classic a
clockwork orange more specifically there
were a few images of fictional
psychopath alex delarge the main
character of the piece he's best
described as a sadistic teenager who
commits heinous crimes and terrorizes
anyone and everyone he encounters simply
for the fun of it is that description
ringing any bells another one of the
most important things to get right when
developing a new joker adaptation is the
character's laugh every actor that has
stepped into that role put a different
spin on it that fit that specific
incarnation perfectly ledger knew he
couldn't simply copy mark hamill or jack
nicholson as that would cheapen the
character so he had to do some digging
and create his own laugh from scratch as
his diary detailed he found his muse in
the form of a hyena the hyena is
synonymous with its laugh a call the
species uses to express any number of
emotions the sound is generally
high-pitched and comes out as a
threatening cackle that's perfect for
the clown prince of crime
in ledger's journal there was at least
one picture of a laughing hyena included
most likely citing his interest in using
their laugh as a starting point for his
own looking back on his performance the
similarities between the two vocal
expressions are rather striking
on january 22nd 2008 heath ledger
tragically passed away at the young age
of 28 due to cardiac arrest according to
the medical examiner his passing came as
a result of an overdose of prescription
medication that brought on a heart
attack it was no secret that ledger went
to serious extremes to slip into
character but did it contribute to his
untimely death after all the last entry
did say quote bye bye so was there any
validity to the claims that joker pushed
ledger over the edge simply put despite
his journal's cryptic nature and his
devotion to the joker rule ledger's
death wasn't a direct cause of his
preparation his drug abuse issues
weren't a new phenomenon and his debut
in the dc universe wasn't driving him
into any kind of depression his sister
kate ledger set the record straight on
her brother's attitude towards the rule
telling reporters at the 2017 tribeca
film festival he wasn't depressed about
the joker his joker diary was very
concerning out of context but it turned
out to be nothing more than a tool by
which ledger was able to pull off the
performance of a lifetime if you or
someone you know is struggling with
addiction please call the substance
abuse and mental health administration's
24 7 national helpline at 1-800-662
that's 1-800-662-4357